listen though y'all I think like when we
sign it I don't think that we should
sign the front I think that's the sign
in the back who picked the picture I did
you don't like it I look like a
butterball but like we don't have a lot
of family pictures together
doors are open
[Music]
oh my God you can take pictures too you
can pop in behind it's okay
thank you we really appreciate that it's
of course
[Music]
oh that's so cute
how y'all doing love thank you so much I
love you guys so much
[Music]
like in public for fans to see us and I
really enjoyed it because like everybody
there is being so supportive and she's
doing pretty well the fans are great we
haven't had no crazy fans and she's
really enjoying it getting to know all
these people my favorite mama
I feel like you're part of my family
thank you I really appreciate that
[Music]
I takes the girls over a week ago with
no response and I've seen on their
social media that they're doing a meet
and greet in Atlanta today
oh hey y'all we have a meet and greet in
Atlanta this week y'all come out and
meet me Lana Josh everybody y'all I'm so
excited to meet all you beautiful faces
make sure to get your tickets linked
down below I love you guys so much
purchase your tickets now we can't wait
to see you there they won't text or call
me back I have no choice then to just
roll up on them today at the meet and
greet part one is a relationship with
them and hopefully this shows them that
I'm willing to go to whatever links to
make this happen
so are you nervous
welfare
you know but they do get a good turnout
you're talking about pulling up and
crashing a party that's not really the
way to Wing them back in they're in a
public place they can't tell me no
[Music]
I mean honestly do you think I should do
it though
sometimes it doesn't turn out good when
you just pop up